hello everyone and welcome back to
versus the show that takes art and makes
it feel like the doctor's never-ending
battle with the master the daleks the
cybermen and james corden i'm your host
for this show mark ellis and today it's
going to be time ward versus time ward
in an epic showdown of two science
fiction titans who held the keys to
everyone's favorite time traveling phone
box apologies to bill and ted whose
phone booth was most excellent we're
talking about david tennant and matt
smith luckily i'm not doing this alone
you see old mark ellis usually writes
his own scripts for verses but in the
world of doctor who i'm a bit of a neo
fighter i'm not that kind of doctor so
i'm aided by head writer of the movie
trivia schmodown pj campbell whose
knowledge and love for all things doctor
who is matched only by his affection for
corgis and mexican pizza so pj and i are
going to hop aboard the tardis and get
this battle for space and time underway
don't expect me to join your little
scooby gang
at some point one of these two time
wards will receive the coveted honor of
being a versus victor here's how we'll
determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash audience score round three
iconic moments round four legacy and
then we'll finally do a wild card round
that could take us to any time any place
just like the tardis itself dinosaurs
on a spaceship and keep in mind i did
say box office which indicates we're
going to be talking about matt smith and
david tennant's entire career but we're
going to be focusing heavily on doctor
who and a shout out to tom baker who
first donned the long scarf and floppy
hat in 1974's cereal robot now it's time
to grab our jelly babies and maybe some
fish fingers and custard and most
importantly do not blink
all right i did it again let's dive into
a wimbly wobbly battle for all the
medical degrees between these two
accomplished actors
[Music]
round one box office
it's common knowledge that money makes
the world go around so the box office
draw of r2 titans of science fiction
seems like a good place to start in the
first corner we have scotland native and
the voice of everyone's favorite penny
pinching duck scrooge david tennant
thanks lad born david mcdonald before
professionally changing his name to
avoid confusion with another actor dt
gained notoriety in geek circles in the
mid-2000s appearing in harry potter and
the goblet of fire and russell t davies
bbc miniseries casanova before being
cast as the replacement for christopher
eccleston's ninth doctor by showrunner
russell t davies for season two of the
newly returned doctor who after a
successful three-season run on the
series and placing himself in the
pantheon of all-time geek icons tenant
would go on to appear in such tv shows
as jessica jones duck tales around the
world in 80 days and films like 2011's
remake of fright night opposite the late
great anton yelchin and the dean devlin
directed bad samaritan that's not to
count the many different stage
adaptations of shakespeare plays
including hamlet starring everyone's
favorite mutant charles xave i'm told
that's not his real name that's actually
sir patrick stewart next time you feel
like showing off
don't in the other corner we've got a
man who needs very little introduction
after being memed across the internet
thanks to morbius it's matt smith though
smith originally had his sights set on
being a professional footballer
appearing in a stage production of 12
angry men with light of fire in him
igniting an affection for acting after a
string of small roles in tv and film
smithwood land the coveted role of the
doctor for outgoing 10th doctor david
tennant for the show's fifth season in
2010 now to be overseen by stephen
moffatt matt smith would be the youngest
actor to ever take on the iconic role of
time lord to that point playing the
character over three seasons before
setting his sights on terminators marvel
heroes queen elizabeth ii and edgar
wright who by the way is in a recent
episode of verses if you want to go
check out our back catalog enough time
for plugs now it's time to talk about
the tardis because this show really
couldn't have survived without david
tennant and russell t davies after their
iconic run or the undeniable matt smith
and maybe making bow ties cool yeah it's
cool bowties are cool are you from
another planet yeah now look i know this
is a whole lot to unpack so just take a
deep breath we're just getting started
first things first
be honest
how do i look now you're probably
thinking hey mark doctor who it's a tv
show not a yeah we know that i just told
you that these two talents have done
quite a bit of entertaining on the big
screen as well and so this round will be
determined by who's had the most success
when we go to the multiplex now it would
be easy to assume that david tennant is
going to run away with this round
because he's one of the most
recognizable actors to come out of
doctor who and has had a much longer
career to date than matt smith however
smith has been a part of some pretty big
properties in his film-going career
in 2008 matt smith's first role would
come in the dark comedy in bruges
starring colin farrell though his role
was ultimately cut after filming after
finishing his time in the tardis smith
would go on to star in ryan gosling's
directorial debut lost river as the
aptly named villain bully though the
movie was mixed critically and didn't do
out the box office matt would start to
gain traction for his performance that
would lead to landing another villainous
role in the fifth film in the terminator
franchise in terminator genesis the film
only pulled in 440 million dollars at
the worldwide box office which
apparently isn't a lot of money and it
killed any traction that led to a next
terminator movie which was just dark
fate another attempt at terminator 3.
maybe it's time for the terminators to
just take a vacation bite me smith would
go on to have a small role in the film
pride and prejudice and zombies before
taking the lead role in the thrillers
patient zero and charlie says the latter
of which is where matt took on the role
of infamous cult leader charles manson
unfortunately for smith his manson
performance would quickly become
overshadowed by tarantino's once upon a
time in hollywood in which yeah manson
would make another appearance but matt's
career continues to bear fruit as he
would get a role in both edgar wright's
last night in soho as well as a sony
adaptation of marvel's character morbius
where he played the central villain a
career pattern i can kind of see coming
off of who is that smith is trying to
shed the madman with a box persona it's
not a box
it's a time machine for more turns
pushing him into a dark place my whole
brain just went what the hell though
unfortunately for matt neither one of
these efforts have lit up the box office
just yet over matt smith's 14 film
appearances his films have still brought
in
645 million dollars with an average of
108 million dollars each which is really
not too shabby for a time ward from
gallifrey but is it enough to compete
with david tennant
david's career starts in 1996 with a
cameo as a drunk undergrad in the
christopher eccleston-led jude that's a
bit of a fun doctor who crossover right
who knew their careers would come
crashing together again in 2005 the tied
wood turned for tenant as he appeared in
that little franchise about that kid
with the scar and he cast spells it's
the fourth film in the harry potter
franchise the goblet of fire and tenet
played the villainous barty crouch jr
after he departed his doctor who days
tenet would then appear in 2011's fright
night taking over the role of peter
vincent from the iconic roddy mcdowell
though tenants got a handful of british
comedies under his belt including the
decoy bride and what we did on our
holiday one of the big things pushing
his box off a success continued to be
his voiceover work a renowned vocal
artist tenets box offices bolstered by
performances in the how to train your
dragon franchise the pirates band of
misfits and ferdinand so you combine
that with the fact that those harry
potter movies tend to do well at the box
office goblet of fire almost made 900
million dollars by itself which alone
overshadows matt smith's entire
filmography over time david tennant has
accumulated a whopping 1.9 billion
dollars at the box office making for a
per movie average of 194 million dollars
so no matter how you cut it even as matt
smith continues to push his career in
new interesting directions and choosing
varied roles david tennant is the
certified box office king in this round
it's still early the game could change
at any minute but tenet has a 1-0 lead
and matt smith looks towards round two
round two tomato meter slash audience
score matt smith is good at a lot of
things like fighting daleks and weeping
angels but he couldn't quite fail tenet
in our last round i really hope he
doesn't hold that against me because if
doctor who has taught us anything we
mere mortals on earth are always in need
of saving and round two might be the
best opportunity for matt to remain
competitive in today's proceedings
because it's all about what the critics
and audiences were saying after they
checked out your projects inside and
outside of the tardis
stay away demon it's a very interesting
turning point here as two famed time
wards feature deep work in both tv and
film the starting point of course should
be the wonderful world of doctor who
which they each start in three seasons
of david tennant from season two through
four under the watchful eyes of russell
t davies and all three of his seasons
are a whopping 100 percent certified
fresh rating you'd think that would be
impossible to match but matt smith's
three year run seasons five through
seven under stephen moffatt bore
shockingly similar results tying at a
hundred percent for all three seasons of
his run those are toy story numbers i've
been thinking about it for a century
1984 terminator level perfection citizen
kane quality wait what citizen kane's at
99
wow who is the sled hater that
that's a topic for another day here
since the flagship show between our two
stars leaves us at somewhat of a
stalemate let's hone in on the rest of
their careers shoot
on the movie side tenets career average
which spans almost 30 years to this
point has an overall critical reception
of 61
and a slightly higher audience rating of
63 percent it's not necessarily
gangbusters yeah but that's because your
database got corrupted but it's enough
to keep david fresh according to our
tomato meter and audience score metrics
matt smith's career is still in the
early days compared to david's but over
the last decade matt's critical
reception has been
it's a little rotten i don't think so
he currently sits at a staggering 48
film average with the critics but
audiences seem to enjoy his films more
leaving him fresh at 61
just behind david tennant it's not a
huge gap but matt's gonna need to step
it up if he wants to tie the score don't
mess with me sweetheart
and the tv careers of these two
thespians begins to shift things in a
new direction dave attendance had an
incredible run on television with so
much material it's hard to keep up with
at times with a career that sprawling
you'd think you'd run into a few duds
but tenant is doing well with a small
screen average of 82 on the tomato meter
and 73 on the audience score it seems
like you all really enjoy everything
from broadchurch and good omens to
jessica jones and around the world in 80
days maybe the less said about
gracepoint the better matt smith overall
has a much smaller but equally as
impressive tv run following doctor who
he set his sight's on the crown where he
played prince philip duke of edinburgh
opposite claire foy as queen elizabeth
ii for the show's first two seasons and
while we've not yet heard anything about
house of the dragon people seem to be
excited for smith being a prominent lead
of the new game of thrones prequel but
that's in the future
or i guess the past we're really bending
time in a lot of different directions
today
overall matt smith's average is a huge
feather in his cap here taking him to 90
percent with the critics and 82 percent
overall with audiences so with that in
mind if you have matt and david tied who
takes this round well there's only one
way to find out over both the film and
television careers of matt smith and
david tennant the two have done some
incredible work and the only way to
break this tie is to find an overall
average combining the film and tv work
of both actors the sith deal in
absolutes i deal with math oh you sexy
thing starting with david tennant's
career the 10th doctor comes in strong
with an overall audience score average
of 67 percent and on the tomato meter
that average rounds up to 71
it's not too shabby for almost 30 years
of effort i could do so much more
so much more
but can matt smith sneak away with a win
here after comparing the two
he might fall a little short his
audience score average is 64 percent
just three percent shy of david and his
overall tomato meter average is 56
percent rotten putting tenet over the
top of matt again in round two it's been
a tough call in both rounds but the
numbers speak for themselves matt i'm
pulling for you and don't worry there's
still three rounds to go don't worry
i'll soon fix that round three iconic
moments while matt smith couldn't quite
catch a break on his last round it
wasn't a total blowout in a very even
matchup for these two icons of sci-fi
that said let's get into round three of
today's verses where we're going to take
a look at the most iconic moments for
smith and tennant both in doctor who and
in their respective careers they're no
strangers to being icons i mean how else
do you think they're on a show as
popular as verses
we only talked the best of the best
starring eric roberts here on the show
and both smith and tennant fit that bill
well
yeah starting with david tennant there's
no doctor who had nearly as many
memorable moments in their time in the
tardis as tenet outside of maybe the
longest running doctor played once again
by the great tom baker from quoting the
lion king dialogue in his first episode
there is more to see than can ever be
seen
more to do than no hold on
sorry that's the lion king to the
absolutely heartbreaking final line i
don't want to go
twice mind you tenet continually
reminded us why he was one of the best
to ever take on the role the 10th
doctor's tardis adventures also led to
some of the biggest episodes in the show
ask any fan about their feelings on the
final minutes of the season 2 finale
doomsday and you're sure to get a
teary-eyed response moreover the 10th
doctor got to reunite with renowned
companion sarah jane smith once again
played by the late great elizabeth
sladen in school reunion also taking on
davros one of the doc's most formidable
foes in the stolen earthen journey's end
as well as beating historical figures
such as bill shakespeare
i hear he prefers william in a long line
of iconic moments in the show no one can
quite match tenant right that's what i
like about you i don't know matt smith
comes pretty close in his three-year run
from hosting the first real multi-doctor
who story in new who opposite david
tennant and john hurt to his final stand
in the time of the doctor eleven
featured many great moments that
constantly wowed the fans from his
brilliant first episode the 11th hour to
arguably one of the greatest hours of tv
and vincent and the doctor or you could
even toss in his ongoing love story with
alex kingston's river song a love tale
so beautiful it spans multiple doctors
and seasons the bulk of which is carried
by smith's 11. these are just some of
the most fulfilling moments of the
program's history between the 10th and
11th doctors it's hard to say who wins
so now we have to look at their bigger
careers to find a victor david tennant's
entire filmography is full of wonderful
exciting and iconic performances many of
which we still talk about today who can
forget his turn as barty crouch jr with
that weird nervous tongue thing a
prominent performance choice that plays
into goblet of fire's biggest reveal or
where he plays a literal singing
detective opposite the walking dead's
david morrissey in blackpool which is a
show you really have to see to believe
but for many younger audiences david
tennant's most iconic work will come in
the form of none other than a popular
reference here on the show scrooge
mcduck in the revival of ducktales which
lasted three seasons and they should be
a hundred percent they're not they
should be 100 of the tomato meter of
course if we're talking memorable
moments tenets turn as the villainous
purple man opposite kristen ritter in
marvel's jessica jones is constantly
touted as one of the best villain
presences marvel's ever had can you get
the sound of him yelling jessica out of
your brain
jessica
unfortunately matt smith man it's gonna
be tough to catch a break in this round
too as awesome as he is for being a meme
in his dance sequence in morbius what a
choice that is matt's other performances
don't offer nearly as many iconic or
standout moments sure he got to appear
in a terminator movie but he didn't have
much to do other than kill john connor
in a blink and you'll miss it sequence
before appearing as a cg monstrosity
later in the film the closest thing to
iconic outside of doctor who we have for
matt smith comes down to almost
appearing in star wars episode 9 before
production went in a new direction with
the story so we're left wondering what
if instead however matt's work on the
crown was touted as exceptional so we
had to give him a tip of the cap for
that preferably a stetson but once again
david tennant is going to win this round
how great was he in that fright night
reboot he stole the entire movie and now
matt smith is losing three to nothing it
means he can't technically win the match
but we still have plenty of time to
celebrate the greatness that is the 10th
and 11th doctor whose
that's not possible
round four legacy
and now we enter the final of our four
rounds before the wild card and we're
gonna be looking at the legacies of both
david tennant and matt smith and again i
know david is up three nothing but we're
still here to celebrate these two and
their incredible legacies and impact in
and outside of the world of doctor who
in the case of matt smith it's early on
in his career we hope it spans decades
so while he doesn't have as much work
behind him as david tennant he still
left quite a mark on doctor who with his
performance it's akin to the idea if you
give gene wilder's willy wonka the
tardis a fun-loving individual with a
dark side just waiting to bubble up from
underneath making everything from bow
ties and fezzas cool again matt's time
in the tardis really felt like a breath
of fresh air for the audience and not
only that matt's years in the tardis had
him accompanied by nebula herself karen
gillen before she debuted in the mcu
this is one of her earliest roles and
the doctor and amy have continued to be
celebrated as one of the great pairings
ever in the tardis thanks to the
wonderful chemistry between smith and
gillen following up on tenant's era was
never going to be easy but matt smith
made it look effortless as well as being
the doctor during the show's 50th
anniversary a monumental benchmark that
let smith moffatt tennant and john hurt
celebrate the legacy to the show matt
smith's most watched episode during this
run a christmas carol would draw over 12
million people at home to tune in for
this christmas day adventure smith's
entire who catalog would average 7.8
million people watching a series on a
weekly basis a remarkable amount when
you consider he was following arguably
the most popular doctor ever in david
tennant who averaged over 8 million per
episode during his run his most watched
episode another christmas one voyage of
the damned uh which is not really
christmas sounding look this isn't a
huge difference between either guy but
tenet once again proves to have just a
little bit more staying power and legacy
over smith it's hard to see anyone else
walking away from this round with a win
the legacy that david has created with
his career and doctor who itself is
virtually unmatched from previously
mentioned iconic performances and
everything from casanova to fright night
tenet has secured his place in the
massive pantheon of geek gods like kevin
smith bruce campbell and charles xav i
keep forgetting that's actually played
by a real guy sir patrick stewart how
many actors can say they've gotten to
play as diverse and popular characters
as the doctor casanova peter vincent
scrooge mcduck hamlet and phillius fogg
tenets run as the doctor and his
companions of rose martha and donna have
all left a lasting mark on the series
and thus the audience so much so that
tenant and tate are returning next year
once again for the 60th anniversary of
doctor who let your speculation begin on
the who what why and how of all this
being possible suffice to say we're very
excited and with that david tennant once
again scores a handy victory over smith
it's four to nothing as we head into the
wild card oh
no no no it's the last category tenets
looking for the first ever skunk in the
history of versus but matt smith might
have something inside that bow tie
no
and now it's time for the wild card
round christmas spirit ah the wild card
is always that it's freaking wild and
what better way to celebrate that notion
than talking about one of the most
exciting aspects of doctor who itself
the christmas specials for those new to
doctor who like i was last month every
year the series would get in the holiday
spirit with a christmas special that's
become a must-watch event on the bbc
while many of the episodes were meant to
be standalone they'd also play into the
bigger stories of the series either as a
fun epilogue to the season before or as
somewhat of a setup for the next season
in the storylines these episodes were
also some of the most interesting and
creatively inspired so how else can we
wrap up an epic battle than by pitting
tennant's christmas specials against
matt smith and deciding whose episode
featured the most holiday spirit tennis
very first one out of the gate
succeeding christopher eccleston's ninth
doctor was the aptly titled the
christmas invasion which saw tenet
mostly knocked out until the episode's
third act one of the better christmas
episodes in his run this one features
rogue killer christmas trees and evil
masked santas but outside of that
christmas doesn't really stand out as
important to the story itself this is
actually going to be a recurring theme
with david tennant's specials as far as
the runaway bride is and that's our
first episode to feature catherine tate
and donna noble christmas is even less
important to the proceedings similarly
the voyage of the damned which is
basically doctor who's remake of the
poseidon adventure is fun and much like
its counterpart it uses the holiday as a
backdrop more than the drama itself
however tennis fourth special the next
doctor feels the most in line with the
holiday spirit though maybe that's just
the victorian era and the snow giving it
that dickensian veneer david morrissey
as the mysterious next doctor is a
welcome addition to the series as is the
reunion between he and tenet following
their work on blackpool which is a
really fun musical mystery series that
again you gotta watch it trust me but
tennis final christmas special the end
of time part one despite being a great
story and featuring the return of john
simm as the master just again doesn't
feel all that christmas-y david tennant
tries he might can't quite finish all
the cookies we left out for him so now
matt smith has an opening can he finally
score a point that would be nice yes
during stephen moffat's tenure as show
runner matt smith got four christmas
specials as the 11th doctor all of which
are really perfect for the holiday
season moffatt infuses every episode of
his christmas specials with the full
spirit of the season starting with
matt's very first outing the aptly
titled a christmas carol which takes a
rather unique approach to the classic
charles dickens novel of the same name
maybe you've heard of it this episode is
a warm blanket that has become a
must-watch for any the in during
christmas his next two episodes the
doctor the widow and the wardrobe and
the snowmen both continued to embrace
the season of giving especially the
snowmen which would also reintroduce an
old school who villain in the great
intelligence as well as jenna coleman's
clara whose impossible girl would become
the focus of the next several seasons of
the show matt's final christmas episode
is the time of the doctor in which the
doctor finds himself stranded in
christmas town and it's 11's final stand
against many of his most formidable
enemies before regenerating into peter
capaldi
it's safe to say that matt smith yes
finally gets a victory in the wild card
round
who demanded
oh so i'm never saying that again fine
his christmas episodes feel like they
couldn't exist without the holiday
spirit and time making them the
quintessential december 25th viewing
every single year
unless your name is phoebe case from
gremlins you're bound to enjoy the
holidays they get even merrier with a
matt smith doctor who episode 11 gets
off the schneid smith avoids being swept
by tenant and it's four to one which
still means david tennant is now
officially our winner of today's match
his name sir
this is the doctor
so tenet is time ward victorious in this
episode of versus and even though matt
smith couldn't quite overtake tenet his
career is not one to sneeze at and we're
excited for what's next for him but who
am i kidding even with all this it's
incredible to see the amount of work
these two have put into their respective
careers and thanks to them and this
assignment you can now count me as one
of the newer doctor who fans welcome
aboard thank you
now it's your turn dear viewer i know
you all love your doctor who who do you
have in this battle for geek supremacy
are you team david or team matt which
era of doctor who is your favorite and
what's your favorite project from each
actor outside of the doctor who cannon
hit me up on social media at mark ellis
live with your take and stay tuned right
here to rotten tomatoes for all the
latest in the world of doctor who matt
smith david tennant and their many
upcoming projects huge shout out to pj
campbell for really manning the tardis
and helping me through this episode
thank you for tuning in to versus i'm
mark ellis and remember kids if you
stumble upon a phone booth tread lightly
it could be bill and or ted's could be
superman's fitting room or it just might
be that magical tardis of course if you
have a real doctor i hope they own a
cell phone so long
you